that was a wild day on Wall Street today
the Dow recorded a swing of 737 points
going from way up to finish down 345 the
S&P 500 was up 40 was off 46 rather the
Nasdaq plunged 212 today let's get some
analysis now and a look at other
business news Deirdre Bolden of the Fox
Business Network joins us from New York
wild day Deirdre
wild day indeed read the lastest 60
minutes of the session stocks fell hard
so tech stocks that fell the most they
dragged markets lower so until recently
tech was a bright spot even on volatile
days it was sort of the one part of the
market that could steady sentiment but
that may be over to companies Facebook
and Nvidia are facing high profile
challenges and hurt the entire tech
sector so Facebook stock is down 20%
from its February high the FTC is
investigating the company for the second
time since its founding about privacy
and data security 37 states attorneys
general are investigating Facebook and
Cook County Illinois taking a one step
further and suing the company so the
lawsuit states that Facebook violated
state fraud law and says Facebook is not
a social media company it is the largest
data mining operation in existence
founder and CEO Mark Zuckerberg will
testify before Congress on April 10th
most experts say Facebook is sure to
face fines or some form of regulation or
both but this specter of regulation
means investors may no longer see tech
as a safe investment but as a risky one
so two other tech CEOs have been invited
to testify at the same hearing Google
CEO Twitter CEO perception of risk
pushing chip giant and Vidia down as
well it's chips go into driverless tech
so last week in uber driver lists car
killed a pedestrian in Arizona so
reports are out that Nvidia is going to
no longer test its products on public
roads so that's clearly a setback for
what the company believed was safe tech
and that stock plunged more than 7
percent today even tech heavyweights
such as Apple Microsoft Amazon all were
affected they all closed in the red by
at least three and a half percent the
Nasdaq down by close to three percent
wiping out almost all of yesterday's
gain so chances are we are going to see
more of this day-to-day market
volatility Brett back to you a lot of
volatility there's a lot of people are
also watching the Department of Justice
trying to block the 85 billion dollar
merger between AT&T and Time Warner this
trials ongoing anything new about that
tonight
so essentially is a consumer-driven
story as you know branding the argument
that the government is making is that
this merger would be unfriendly to
consumers having us all pay more for our
data our cable every single thing that
we use and of course both the lawyers on
AT&T Time Warner side saying not at all
true so we will see who wins out will be
following it for the next few weeks
Brett all right we'll follow it Deirdre
as always thank you